que geneviève bahler directrice de
l'hôtel quatre étoiles littré à paris
bonsoir je me lève merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france alors on l'a
vu ces nouvelles mesures vont une
nouvelle fois impacté l'hôtellerie à
paris d'autant plus que 40% des hôtels
sont déjà fermés et ce chiffre pourrait
monter à 70 % la faute à un manque de
touristes en premier lieu oui pour
l'instant nous n'avons aucune demande
sur le mois de juillet est très peu sur
le mois d'août la clientèle
internationale fait complètement défaut
à paris le mois de juillet deux mois
d'août à paris sont généralement des
mois très très calme
sauf que la clientèle internationale est
totalement absente cette année comme
l'année dernière d'ailleurs donc
généralement ce sont les américains les
brésiliens et les canadiens l'année rien
n'étant pas du tout reparti c'est une
une clientèle qui nous fait défaut
et finalement quand vous avez deux pour
cent entre 2 et 5 % de taux d'occupation
la question ne se pose pas il faut bien
rester fermés que d'ouvrir à l'hôtel
avec aucune clientèle possible
alors on l'a vu il ya pas mal de tels
qu'ils sont d'ores et déjà fermés 40% on
l'a vu avec ce chiffre est ce que selon
vous ces hôtels pourraient fermer de
manière définitive s'il n'y a pas une
réaction de la part du gouvernement
alors je pense que la situation oui est
grave
s'il n'y a pas un maintien des aides y
compris sur l'activité partielle ou le
fonds de solidarité qui normalement
s'arrête fin août
je pense que certains de mes confrères
vont disparaître particulièrement tous
les gens qui ont pris des pg e et
l'absence de clientèle eux pas de
chiffre d'affaires si franchement les
aides ne perdure pas on va avoir
beaucoup de mal à s'en sortir
beaucoup de vos confrères dénoncent un
manque un manque dette de la part
d'états en tout cas ce n'est pas
suffisant pour eux est ce que c'est
votre avis également qu'est ce que vous
demandez aujourd'hui aux pouvoirs
publics c'est à dire ce qu'il faut voir
surtout comme situation c'est que o
mois de juillet les aides diminuent au
mois d'août encore plus et elle s'arrête
à fin août donc une ouverture au mois de
septembre sans aucune aide et des
charges fixes que continue à être très
importantes sur le mois de juillet et
-12 ne va pas nous permettre de démarrer
une activité et je pense que les gens
qui ont des loyers à payer
il y aura plus d'être sur les loyers et
là ça va être catastrophique et j'ai
très peur que effectivement le marché de
l'hôtellerie et des hôteliers soit dans
l'impossibilité de continuer leur
activité et je crois qu'il va y avoir de
lourdes conséquences pour l'hôtellerie
en général et plus particulièrement pour
l'hôtellerie parisienne
alors oui je le rappelle vous êtes
directrice de l'hôtel quatre étoiles
littré à paris comment vous avez subi
comment vous avez vécu cette cette crise
sanitaire à titre personnel pas écouté
on peut dire qu'il faut garder le moral
parce que ça sert à rien de de perdre le
moral c'est très difficile on est resté
en contact avec nos employés
régulièrement je pense que eux aussi
espèrent revenir le plus tôt possible
les charges fixes continuent à courir il
faut pas croire que les hôteliers sont
en repos quand ils ont fermé leur hôtel
au contraire je vais vous dire on a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup de travail
parce que on a quand même des des
activités comme faire couler l'eau dans
les chambres fait vider les vides et
certaines réserves
enfin voilà il faut il faut la présence
et c'est pas des vacances croyez moi
merci beaucoup je ne la valeur d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directrice de l'hôtel quatre
étoiles littré à paris